[Music]
i'm here today to
take it to a slightly different
direction and
talk about something that we've worked
on for a while
on the application side and i
love to kind of share that journey with
everyone
so again really quickly my name is grace
wong i lead
a team of scientists engineers at
netflix
and we focus on working on algorithms
that help personalize
member outreach on growth and some of
the art market marketing algorithms
and so uh what i'll do today is to take
everyone
through a journey of how we think
through
a specific personalization product that
we've created in the past
um so if you're like me
living the us uh in the bay area
uh you probably spend the past few
months uh at home
a lot of time at home um and if you're
like me at the end of the day
i just wanna sink down my couch and turn
on my tv
and you know enjoy uh being like a show
so
and netflix our mission is to provide
really relevant and compelling stories
um to delight our members um we want to
spark joy
and there are a number of different ways
to do it obviously the first way to do
it is to create really really compelling
content
so that we can share that with our
members um
another way to do it is actually to work
on
a personalized product such that we can
personalize every single member's
experience
and tailor our recommendations
and outreach to our member to the
specific member
that we really value um and so um
as part of that um you know if we create
better content we
firmly believe that our members will
enjoy our service more
um and similar to that we believe that
if we improve our personalization
of the various in-app as well as
out-of-app
experience we're able to make more
relevant recommendations to our users
and our members will be able to find
relevant content to enjoy
um so that's really the core of um
the the personalization product that
we're talking about today which is
that we want to create um a system
where we have a way to reach out to our
members effectively
with different channels and we want to
be able to deliver
useful engagement messages like
hey here is some interesting product and
content that you might enjoy
as well as important information like
someone's accounts
payments and a lot of uh
important notifications for the users
so there are a few different ways we can
reach out to our users
we have emails and so
in the body of the email we might have a
lot of different types of content that
we think might be engaging for the users
a lot of folks are on their phones on
their mobile devices a lot
so we also use push notifications as a
way
to reach out to our users and finally um
in some situations we actually do need
to reach our users in a very timely
manner so
we also take advantage of things like
sms to send really relevant information
like hey here's your verification code
and this is how you can sign into the
account
and uh if you look at um what's outside
of these kind of outbound channels
um inside the app itself either on tv
uh or on the mobile devices um we also
have a center
where we have all kinds of notifications
that we deliver to our user and so
you can see this example of you know a
little badge at the bottom
and you know that's where we have a list
of past notifications and current
notifications that we want to deliver to
the user
and sometimes it even shows up as a
pop-up on the tablet
if it's a really key piece of
information that we need
to address right away and so all of
these
are essentially orchestrated
by a single system and
we can think of it as a message
management system
uh where we can manage a very large
variety of
message types um so i just want to show
a few
uh quick examples of how they might look
like so the first
one is an example of some
recommendations we might have
for a user um the second
is an example where perhaps we'll have a
new title that is coming into our
catalog
or a new piece of original content that
we produce
and we want to make sure that our
members are aware of that
perhaps you have a favorite show if
there's a new season
that has just arrived we would ping our
members about a new season arrival
uh that they might find relevant um and
finally we provide some sneak previews
of content as well so
you know you know stand up thing to our
users hey clear your weekend
uh here's a show that you might want to
make sure that you uh watch on a
saturday night
uh and so so we have a lot of different
message types these are just
a very small sample of what they look
like um
and at the core of it is we need to have
a system that
orchestrates and send these to different
channels
but most importantly also make a
decision
on what to send and when to send to a
user
so um if you think about how to do that
a really simple approach would be to
create some sort of decision engine
where you might
create a number of heuristics that say
something like
if you have watched stranger things
season one
then most likely you're going to enjoy
stranger things season two
um but if we already sent you something
similar in the past few days
uh let's not send that to you again so
we don't uh
create color in someone's email box for
example
so that's a really simple approach um
but you can imagine that over time this
can become unruly it can become really
difficult to manage
and so a smarter way to approach this is
obviously to
drive the decision engine with some sort
of machine learning based approach
such that the system can actually
from past observations figure out
what sort of messages to send to whom
and when
and how often and hopefully this is a
system that will
you know sustain itself and learn over
time
and that's exactly what i want to take
everyone through today
so let's let's kind of think through um
what it would take to create a system
like that
so um first of all we want to make sure
that
it is a personalized experience so we
want to make sure that we are making a
decision
uh for every single member differently
according to what we know about the user
um and
we want to make sure that we deliver the
most relevant
messages to the users we don't want to
just send everything we have possible
for the users
um and another component that's
important is that it has to be timely
so uh you know
a new piece of information or a new
piece of title that has just arrived
uh we want to make sure that that is
notified in a timely fashion
and we want to make sure that that is
done at the right moment in time
such that it will create uh the the most
joy for the member
and if you think about creating a system
like this
if it's going to learn over time
effectively we need to create a system
that is able to mitigate as much
bias in the data as possible so that
when we
learn the model the model is not just an
outcome of what we've done in the past
but also
the model is adapting to what's
happening right now in the world
we want to maximize the impact of the
system and so
if we want to maximize joy for our
members
we want to make sure that every decision
we make
and every message we send is actually
leading to
someone uh actually enjoying a title
uh we don't want to send an email if we
don't think that
sending that email is going to lead to
someone discovery a really interesting
piece of
new content and finally
we have this tension between reward and
cost
so the reward is that we want to have
some sort of
member satisfaction but we cannot send
an unlimited number of messages we
certainly do not want to be
in a situation where we're sending push
notifications to someone's phone
every 10 minutes and so there is
some explicit and some implicit costs
that we do need to consider
when we are designing such a system so
let's talk through each of these
components separately
so in order to personalize
the messaging decision we can think of
it as
effectively trying to optimize
the outcome which in this case is member
satisfaction
and we can do that by uh effectively
learning a model
that will either predict um the uh
a binary variable of whether or not
someone's enjoyed their service and
their many ways of representing that
uh or a continuous amount
of that represents how much someone has
enjoyed the service
um and we can create a model using a
number of features that is
specific to a user in order to create a
personalized experience
so we might use information like which
country the user is in
we might use information like what sort
of past
engagement behavior they might have with
netflix to learn about their preferences
we might even use information like time
of day
day of week to give us that additional
time context
so that we can make a prediction a
little bit better
so this boils down to uh training a
model
uh either a classification model or a
regression model
uh that estimates uh the probability
that someone
is going to enjoy uh
our service um at a certain time of day
um
but every all the information that we
know about the user
and there are a variety of techniques to
do that there's a lot of linear
techniques
regressions uh tree based models neural
networks and
depending on how much nonlinear effect
you want to capture in the model
there are some better choices than the
others
so this is a pretty simple framework and
we can certainly do that
and but we talked about the second
component which is that
you know we don't just train a model and
be done
this is a living system it's an evolving
system so
we want to actually make sure that we
create a sustainable system where we
continuously have a stream of data that
is
unbiased such that we can train on it
and we can continuously
update uh this model and so let's talk
about
um what are some ways to think about how
we might
remove bias from the system um so when
we talk about bias a lot of people think
about
uh explore exploit and so the the
idea is really that while we want to
exploit as much as possible what we know
about the users and
what we can learn from that and create
the best decision
to recommend the messages for the user
we want to also
uh reserve a little bit of a portion of
the data we have
for learning right and so um that
comes at a cost to our exploitation in
the sense that
we will not necessarily be making the
optimal decision
if we are learning however that will
give us a source
of data that would be as unbiased as
possible
so there are a lot of commonly used
techniques for that
the simplest is the epsilon greedy where
you basically say
for x percent of the time uh we're going
to
make a random decision so in our case
let's map it back to the messaging
problem
for x percent of the time we're going to
send some combination
of messages at a certain point of time
and we're going to learn what happens
when we do that
so what does the member do how do they
react to that when we send that certain
combinations
of messages um and then for some other
time
we're actually going to make a smart
decision we're actually going to use
everything we know at the moment
and try to make a best decision for
example by using the model that we've
learned
to determine what combination of
messages we will want to send to our
user
um and there are also techniques like
the upper confidence interval
where we can effectively take advantage
of the uncertainty
that we can estimate
of the different combinations of
messages that we can potentially send to
the users
and choose a combination such that uh
it has the highest confidence bound
meaning that you know we
potentially know the least about it but
also is it's optimistic
um and uh learn about what happens uh
when we make that decision
and finally there is techniques like
thomson sampling
where we can construct a posterior
distribution and basically sample from
that and so
sample from the likelihood and
figure out uh what happens when we send
a specific sample sampled from this
posterior distribution
and with that message combination what
we can learn
and so all these are common techniques
and that provides
us a constant stream of data that is
relatively biased
so that we can make sure that our model
is really not just a product
of its own outcome and so kind of to
give a very specific example of how that
might look like
um if we let's say take epsilon greedy
uh as
the uh method of choice um for
export exploit then what we could
effectively do is
for some percent of the time we're going
to
choose a random message or a random
combination of messages and send that to
the users
and for some other percentage of time
we're going to look at
information we have about a user such as
country
past behavior some sort of like
day of week time of day context and then
make a best decision
uh using the model that we trained
earlier and
uh and then determine what combination
of messages we might send to the users
um and a lot of you might recognize that
this is essentially a very simple
contextual bandit set up
uh where we take advantage of this
export void paradigm but at the same
time
in the exploit arm we are able to
incorporate information
we know and try to make a best decision
in the face
of a little bit of uncertainty
and there are a lot of other uh devising
techniques as well
uh some of them take advantage of the
fact that
uh we can try to up sample
uh training data where we have the least
amount of knowledge on
and so without going to detail
we can essentially estimate propensities
of certain
uh certain combinations of messages and
we can
re-weight our training data if the
occurrence
of those actions is very rare um or
uh alternatively we can choose to inject
a little bit of a noise um and so we can
inject a little bit of a noise
to uh the policy that we feel relatively
confident about
and observe the outcome and and use that
as a way to de-bias
the data that we have and so when we're
talking about these techniques
is it's going to be hard to really
decouple that from the concept
of uh causality right so
um to put it really simply uh we really
want to ask her a question of you know
if a subscriber come and visit netflix
and they watch a movie uh is it because
the message we sent
was really relevant and it was really
helpful uh
or that you know they would have come
anyway and they would have come watch a
show and enjoy
uh a tv show anyway even if we did not
reach out right is is
is the message really really driving
that additional uh enjoyment
uh from our member um and that's a
really key question when i want to ask
uh because uh again we don't want to
send
a message to a user if we don't truly
believe that it's going to bring that
additional enjoyment uh we're not going
to help them find
the relevant content that they might
enjoy and so
i want to talk a little bit about how we
might maximize the causal impact of the
system we built
um and so you know we talked a little
bit earlier about building a model
that tries to estimate the probability
that someone would enjoy our service or
estimate how much they might enjoy the
service using
a user and time and additional context
that model really is only correlational
right so we
we are constructing it from our past
observations
um and that only captures that uh
correlational aspect of those
relationship but
uh remember that every observation or
every role of data we have
is really influenced by past actions
from our messaging system
and so we want to make sure that we
incorporate it
um and so in this case uh when we're
estimating
uh the probability that someone would
enjoy our service given all the
user features we have what we could
really do is to model it as
the probability that someone is going to
enjoy our service
given that all the information we have
about the users and time of days and
additional contacts
and that we have sent them a certain
combinations
of messages in the past and so this this
context that we're adding here which is
the past
personalized decision making that we
want to incorporate
into the model is essentially going to
help us
control uh for that final probability
is going to help us add a causal
component
to what we're estimating here and so
a really simple way to think about how
we might use it is
if we estimate that someone
is going to enjoy uh our service
uh by uh you know being
someone in the u.s uh having watched a
lot of shows in the past
um and uh uh is uh
um have also been sent an email about uh
stranger things uh coming uh season two
coming
um if we think that propensity
is going to be a lot higher than for
example
the same person not having been sent
with that exact same message
um then we think that it's worth it to
send a message
um so another way to say this is
we really want to make sure that there
is a lot of incrementality
in the likelihood that we're
someone is going to enjoy our service by
receiving an email versus not receiving
an email
and that income mentality is really the
crux
of a lot of what we do here we want to
make sure that
that is maximized such that the decision
we make for the users
is causal um
so um we can do that and that's a that
would that would make for a pretty great
policy where
uh we effectively only send a message uh
if the incrementality
of someone enjoying our service it's
high
um but if we do that
you can still imagine a world where
there's always going to be a little bit
of incrementality
increase when we send a message because
let's face it we all like to
uh you know mindlessly click through our
phone sometimes and
uh swipe through uh you know uh contents
and recommendations that are given to us
um but is more really better
and in this case uh we actually firmly
believe that we
do not want to send an
amount of messages to a user that is
unbounded
and so we really want to think of this
as
uh hey we want to impose a volume
constraint
on the amount of messages we're willing
to send our user
we want to be very judicious with our
decision and we are only willing to send
a message
when we think that it's going to lead to
a very large amount of enjoyment
of our member um and so a few different
ways of doing it a simplest way of doing
it is really just to determine some sort
of threshold for the incrementality
and so we would only send an
additional message if we think that that
additional message
is some amount more increment
incremental than what would have sent so
far
um and now of course tuning uh that what
that threshold is
is going to be tricky but there are a
lot of different ways of thinking about
it and they would incorporate
equal parts science as well as equal
parts as like product vision
in this case and there are also a lot of
different flavors of reinforcement
learning in the recent years very active
areas of research
where folks are trying to say hey we are
treating this as a bandit problem where
we actually have a budget constraint
and so in the ad space for example this
is a very common problem
in our case our budget constraint is
effectively
how much messages we're willing to send
and so that's another way of a really
good way of framing this problem
um so let's take the really simple
example of sending an incrementality
threshold and if we put it back together
with
kind of what we worked out earlier again
we can
use something like epsilon greedy
algorithm to do a really simple export
exploit
um in the explore arm again we randomly
sample
from frequencies and candidate message
distributions to determine what
combination of messages to send
and then in the exploit arm we can now
use the model we constructed with the
causal component
where we basically have estimates for if
we are to send a message versus if we
are not to send a message and then
additional layers on top of that to
estimate the incrementality of sending
a specific message at a given time and
then our policy will
basically quickly assemble the set of
messages to send
uh subject to some predefined
incrementality threshold
and so we would keep sending until we
determine that
the next message is really not going to
drive any material
member enjoyment anymore and we would
stop at that point
um and uh if we if we have a setup like
this
we really want to make sure that we have
some sort of offline valuations
available before we take it online and
so
uh this is uh an example
that uh someone might use in something
like a replay
uh offline evaluation so let's say we
have six different users
we can look at our explorer policy and
gather all the reward
that we can collect from all these data
and then we might have a policy
that we want to evaluate at that given
moment and the way we can evaluate it is
effectively go through every single
entry of
the data that we collected from the
policy that we're trying to evaluate and
match it back
to the explore policy and if we have a
match
in the exact same actions we've taken so
in this case
it would be the exact same combinations
of emails we send then we can collect
the reward
but if there is not a match then we do
not and so by doing that
we can effectively replay our policy
and get a count or an estimate of
how well a given policy that we're
trying to evaluate
perform relative to the observations
we've had in the past
and finally most importantly we want to
take this online
uh and so we always run a b tasks on all
of these personalized experience
um and a b test is still the final
uh oracle in terms of helping us
understand what long-term behavior and
impact of a given policy or a given
algorithm is
and so we have in fact taken
some of these variants that we talked
about online in production and
i just want to quickly show a chart
where
we have a non-personalized variant uh
represented in green uh where uh the
x-axis
is how many emails or messages someone
may receive on a given
a week and then the y-axis is the
density or the count of that
you can see that for a non-personalized
algorithm
it is uh clustered very closely around
some number um and uh it
because it's unpersonalized most people
will effectively receive
a similar amount of messages versus when
we try out a few of these different
techniques i mentioned
uh and and create a personalized
experience
we effectively have a more spread out
distribution meaning that
uh for folks who we believe is going to
uh uh respond and enjoy the messages we
send to them more
we will send more versus for folks who
really were not going to enjoy that
we make sure that we do not send them
messages that are not useful and we
are very careful and judicious in the
amount and
types of emails we send so
um to recap uh you know we chatted about
uh
uh like a framework to think about how
we might construct
a personalized messaging system we want
to make sure that it's personalized and
timely
we want to make sure that the system is
sustainable and is free
of bias as much as possible over time we
want to make sure that it's very
impactful especially
from a causal standpoint and we want to
make sure that we're balancing
the amount of messages to send with that
final volume uh because we want to make
sure every single message we send is
impactful and is actually truly relevant
and useful for our member
and in fact all these requirements and
principles
really apply to any personalized systems
and there's really a lot of exciting
future work in this area both
in the messaging space specifically but
also in
uh in this general area as well um
and you can check out more in this link
to a paper
that we've had with a lot more detail
here um
but i i hope this is like a interesting
introduction to
a framework for how we might think about
tackling a personalization problem
specifically in the messaging space
um so finally i just want to say this is
work
that is done by a lot of folks on the
team
a lot of scientists and engineers for
many years i'm merely here to represent
them
and as well as a lot of really great
work by our
cross-functional partners and so i want
to thank them for their work and i want
to thank everyone here today for
spending the time with us
[Music]